من الخبر الذي هز العالم الفني على خلفيه
اتهامه باغتصاب وضرب فتاه في اكتوبر 2016
قضت محكمه الجنايات في فرنسا بسجن المطرب
المغربي سعد المجرد لست سنوات مداولات
المحكمه استمرت لسبع ساعات يوم الجمعه قبل
النطق بالحكم المحكمه تقول انها مقتنعه
بوقوع حادث الاغتصاب الذي وصفته المدعيه
بشكل دقيق ولم تتغيري روايتها المدعي
العام طالب ايضا بحظر دخول مجرد الى فرنسا
لمده خمس سنوات بعد قضاء عقوبته لكن النجم
المغربي نفل اتهامات المنسوبه اليه واصر
على رفض روايه الاغتصاب او اقامه علاقه مع
المدعيه لا تزال هناك فرصه امام المجرد
الاستئناف الحكم خلال عشره ايام ويمكن
وقتها ان تزيد فتره العقوبه او تقل او
تبقى نفسها حسب تطورات القضيه